hey this is presto Walker and you're
watching mind your decisions here's a
challenging problem from an SAT test in
a class of P students the average
arithmetic mean of the test scores is 70
in another class of n students the
average of the scores for the same test
is 92 when the scores of the two classes
are combined the average of the test
scores is 86 what is the value of P
divided by n this comes from a Quora
discussion of some of the most difficult
SAT math problems you have an average of
about two minutes to solve each problem
I'll also note that my videos will make
you so smart that even difficult
problems like this will become easy to
you and you'll see people asking in the
comment section for harder problems and
it's the best proof that these videos
are teaching math to people around the
world can you figure it out now before I
get to the solution I want to debut a
new feature it's called you feature me I
feature you on May 14th 2018 this is
insider featured my video about the
lighthouse puzzle that's stumping
everyone do check out their article and
my video to see what everyone is talking
about
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem let's
translate each sentence into a
mathematical equation the first sentence
says that if you take the sum of the
test scores for the first class divided
by the number of students which is P you
get an average score of 70 in other
words the sum of all the scores is equal
to 70 times P we can do a similar
equation for the second sentence we have
the sum of all the scores in that class
divided by its number of students n is
equal to 92 which means the sum of all
the scores in the second class is equal
to 92 times n now when we combined the
scores of the two classes we get the
combined sum of the scores divided by
the combined number of students this is
P plus n and that ratio is equal to 86
so the sum of all of the scores is equal
to 86 times the quantity P plus n so
what can we do with these three
equations let's first write c1 for class
one c2 for class two and then the third
equation becomes C 1 plus C 2 we don't
directly see how we can get to P divided
by n so let's experiment with these
equations if you look at the first two
equations we can add them together to
get c1 plus c2 is equal to 70 P plus 92
n now we have something we can work with
we have one expression for C 1 plus C 2
and we have another expression for C 1
plus C 2 so let's equate these two
expressions we have a 70 P plus 92 n is
equal to 86 times the quantity P plus n
which will then distribute to be 86 P
plus 86 n well now get all of the N
terms on the left hand side and all of
the P terms on the right hand side so we
have 6 n is equal to 16 P and we can
simplify this to get pede
by n is equal to 6 over 16 and that's
our answer now this is one way we can
solve the problem but knowing this
method there's actually a shortcut and
on an exam you might need to know the
shortcut to solve it as quickly as
possible so let's take a look at this
problem again from the first sentence
notice that the average in the class of
piece students is 70 now 86 minus 70 is
equal to 16 so this class is 16 off from
the average and there are P students so
the difference is 16 times P in the
second class the average is 92 which is
6 above the average and this class has n
students so we have 6 times n now
because these two classes average out
together we can say that 16 P has to be
equal to 6 n and we directly get that P
divided by n is equal to 6 over 16 so
this is a little shortcut that you might
need to use if you ever have this type
of problem in an exam did you figure it
out thanks for watching this video these
math videos inspire and build confidence
for people around the world and they
already have over a hundred million
views but the math meanies never praise
them and spread their negativity let's
be extra positive to cancel them out
please help by subscribing for free to
get the newest videos and watching and
sharing all of mind your decisions
videos you can also email me a puzzle or
math topic presh at mind your decisions
calm and if you so choose you can check
out my books which are listed in the
video description and support me on
patreon to earn exclusive rewards thanks
for watching and thanks for your support